the revolution comes to an end as Bernie
Sanders drops out of the race or has he
we will examine the strange and
unconvincing way Bernie suspended his
presidential campaign and try to figure
out whether or not there's a future for
the Sandinistas then President Trump
smacks down the World Health
Organization and China but I repeat
myself
and finally the mailbag all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show Bernie Sanders has
ended his presidential campaign or has
he or did he you know one of the
recurring features of the 2016 campaign
is that long after Hillary Clinton had
locked up the Democratic nomination all
the Bernie bros kept posting these
articles like one weird way that Bernie
could still be the nominee or you know
it's like mid 2018 one weird way Bernie
could still win in 2016 well it turns
out there actually is some weird way in
which Bernie could get the nomination
this time or at least have a lot of
power in the Democratic Party Bernie
isn't giving that up yet and so his
pulling out is a little questionable
we'll get to that in a second first I
want to thank our friends at zip
recruiter you know it's really nice
right now to see so many great American
companies doing everything that they can
to help us get through this difficult
time unprecedented time in our country's
history
zip recruiter is one of our longest
standing advertising partners we are
really really pleased to work with them
today they wanted to do something
different than the sort of type of stuff
you're used to so here's a message from
our sponsor zip recruiter right now we
cannot be overwhelmed we have to work to
keep our loved ones safe and protect our
communities we have to work to stay
strong to stay connected to stay focused
we have to work to inspire to innovate
to build new solutions but for all of
this to work we have to work together
it's zip recruiter we connect employers
and people every day but today is
different we're partnering with first
responders government officials the
medical community the innovators and the
manufacturing transportation and
distribution industries to make sure
we're finding the right people for the
right jobs right now let's work together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
is the Sanders campaign really over well
Bernie says it is so I guess we should
take him at his word right maybe I'm not
so sure here yes we announce some 300
delegates behind Vice President Biden
and the path toward victory is virtually
impossible so while we are winning the
ideological battle and while we are
winning the support of so many young
people and working people throughout the
country I have concluded that this
battle for the Democratic nomination
will not be successful and so today I am
announcing the suspension of my campaign
okay
open-and-shut case he says he's
suspending his campaign he's suspending
his campaign except the thing with
Bernie is Bernie never just gives up
Bernie never just goes away so as I'm
listening to this I'm just waiting for
the turn you know the but the however
the old though in the in the statement
and eventually it comes because bernie
is dropping out of the race but he's not
endorsing Joe Biden he's not releasing
his delegates to Joe Biden and he
doesn't even want to stop winning
delegates in the Democratic primary sure
doesn't sound quite like he's dropping
out to me let me also say this I will
stay on the ballot in all remaining
states and continue to gather delegates
while Vice President Biden will be the
nominee
we must continue working to assemble as
many delegates as possible at the
Democratic convention where we will be
able to exert significant influence over
the party platform and other functions
then together standing united we will go
forward to defeat Donald Trump the most
dangerous president in modern American
history Bernie Bernie you scheming
communists now we are going to be
dropping out of the race except we're
going to continue to be on all
the ballots and I encourage all of you
to vote for me and I want to get many
more delegates but their total look Joe
Biden he's totally gonna be the nominee
right but give me all the delegates and
they're you know we'll see what happens
at the convention okay not not much of
an endorsement of Joe Biden what's going
on here well a few things I think Bernie
Sanders has never been the leading man
right Bernie Sanders has always been the
thorn in the side of Democrats and so it
very well made may be the case that
Bernie Sanders is just gonna try to
build up his leverage and get some more
delegates and then go to the convention
and try to make them a little bit more
socialist though I suspect he won't
succeed at that however I'm not totally
convinced that that's the case I'm not
totally convinced Joe Biden is gonna be
the nominee and from what Bernie says it
doesn't quite sound like that either I
think there's a lot of uncertainty now
as to who the nominee is going to be you
know I love that right now Joe Biden is
the only candidate left in the
Democratic presidential race and his old
boss Barack Obama still hasn't endorsed
him it's very strange you would expect
Obama to endorse Joe Biden very early
certainly it would have expected it to
endorse Joe Biden by the time he looked
like he locked up the nomination he
hasn't even endorsed him now that he's
the last guy in the race and I think
Bernie Sanders is looking at that and I
think the Democratic establishment is
looking at that I think Andrew Cuomo in
New York is looking at that and he's
saying I don't know if Joe is gonna be
the guy so Bernie Sanders is doing the
responsible thing it's kind of the PR
move that he has to do to get out of the
race especially with coronavirus because
he's not allowed to campaign he's not
allowed to hold rallies he's considered
to be imperiling people's health if he
even encourages them to go out to vote
so he's kind of been backed into a
corner here by the Democratic
establishment and I guess by this
coronavirus and he he can't really move
one way or the other so he's got to drop
out but he's dropping out without really
dropping out he's dropping out while
still trying to have a lot of influence
at the convention in any case no matter
what Bernie's designs are it does seem
as though his campaign ultimately is
over you know it's it's headed for
destruction does look as though Bernie's
come to the end of
line of his career in American politics
which has now spanned five decades and
assuming all of that is true I would
just like to say Bernie Sanders is an
anti-american old communist who has
campaigned his entire life for an evil
ideology that should be rejected by
every decent human being everything
Bernie has ever contributed to politics
is evil and we are all better off now
that his career is over and if I could
spit on the grave of his campaign I
would do it there I just you know I
wanted really to have a nice moment to
say goodbye to the Bernie campaign I
mean it it's terrible there's nothing
good to say about it his career has been
awful it has been a pox on American
politics the whole country would have
been so much better off if that man had
never run for any office in Burlington
Vermont or elsewhere and I'm very very
very pleased to know that his career is
over
or soon to be over now that means that
as of now the very likely nominee is
going to be Joe Biden but it doesn't
mean that Bernie Sanders has had no
impact on the Democratic Party you know
part of Bernie's farewell I guess
farewell to the Troops is to say even
though we lost the electoral battle
we've actually won the ideological war
and I have to say the sad fact is
Bernie's 50-year career has actually
been somewhat effective at least on
changing the conversation within the
Democratic Party good morning and thank
you very much for joining me I want to
express to each of you my deep gratitude
for helping to create an unprecedented
grassroots political campaign that has
had a profound impact in changing our
nation it has it has before Bernie
Sanders really exploded in 2016 some of
these radical socialist policies were
simply unacceptable the the moniker
socialist was unacceptable in American
politics without Bernie Sanders there's
no way that you see AOC and Ilhan Omar
and Rasheeda till they even the holes
what and all the people who were
avowedly socialists you know Bernie when
he became a senator in 2006 he was an
independent but he referred to himself
as a socialist this was so shocking to
people now it's been normalized and
actually the majority of young Americans
identify as socialist even though only
32% of them can actually define what
socialism is still that's a big sea
change now as of right now Joe Biden
will be the nominee Biden is different
than Bernie Biden is not enraptured by a
an evil ideology Joe Biden doesn't
really have any kind of ideology at all
Joe Biden is an empty suit he's just the
kind of politician who wants his name on
the post office it is worth pointing out
though that Joe Biden for his perhaps
ideological I can't call it moderation I
could call it rudder listen us you know
he just doesn't really have any
principles at all for all of that it's
worth pointing out he's been wrong on
just about everything for his also five
decade career in politics and a great
recent example of this because he's you
can go all the way back to the 70s and
find things he was wrong on but a great
recent example is in 2011 in 2011 Joe
Biden was talking about the rise of
China as one of the great geopolitical
phenomenons of our lifetime and now
during coronavirus during the trade war
that we just recently had the role of
China is is more important than any
other role in Foreign Affairs Joe Biden
got China completely wrong remarkable
absolutely remarkable transformation
even back then it was clear that that
there was that great things were
happening and there was also a debate
there was a debate here in the United
States and quite frankly throughout most
of the West is whether a rising China
was in the interest of the United States
in the wider world as a young member of
the Foreign Relations Committee I wrote
and I said and I believe then what I
believe now that a rising China is a
positive positive development not only
for China but for America and the world
writ large is it possible that Joe Bai
could have been more wrong about that I
know he's not the only one who said this
a lot of people on the Left said this
the some people on the right even said
that and it just wasn't true a rising
China has been absolutely devastating
for the United States it was a mistake
and the people who encouraged it were
wrong and should be held accountable for
it
they should not be elected president but
that's Joe Biden and Joe Biden wasn't
just wrong on China then Joe Biden was
wrong on China as late as January in
February of this year remember when
President Trump closed up travel with
China Joe Biden accused him of
xenophobia it was terrible that the
during a pandemic in China a pandemic
that was caused by China we would cut
off travel from China he has been so
welcoming of China he's been a China
first politician in some ways or at
least China on an equal par with
everybody else because a rising China is
good for everybody
including the United States and that was
just dead wrong Joe Biden by the way who
fancies himself a foreign policy expert
we'll get to some additional problems
with that in just a second first I've
got to thank our friends over at Wonder
II you know now is a great time to be
listening to podcasts at one that I
really love I love hearing about the
stories of some of America's greatest
companies competing against one another
and that's why I want to tell you about
a weekly podcast from Wonder E called
business Wars each season digs deep into
some of the greatest corporate rivalries
of all time think Facebook versus
snapchat or Nike versus adidas on each
episode you will get an inside look at
what has inspired entrepreneurs to take
risks that drove their companies to new
heights or into the ground I think
you'll really like it and then afterward
you can obviously get it on Apple
podcasts Spotify or wherever you are
listening right now okay so Joe Biden
dead wrong on China Joe right Joe Biden
dead wrong on just about everything
including his own name including where
he is but don't forget I mean I think
it's easy to say now the biggest problem
with Joe's campaign is that he's senile
and he's not the man he was ten years
ago even if he were the man he was ten
years ago he is not the man for this
moment okay
he's been so wrong
so many things and the China issue is
not going away because China has
infiltrated international organizations
all over the world okay they've now
infiltrated four of the largest
international organizations on earth no
other country has come to dominate even
more than one of them and so China's
made a big effort this way
one of the organizations that China has
taken over is the World Health
Organization they've taken over the
World Health Organization by installing
one of their puppets to run the place
and that puppet is now paying off
because that puppet is accusing not so
implicitly Donald Trump of causing more
body bags in the corona virus pandemic
and he's saying that if you at all raise
any political questions about the World
Health Organization you two are going to
be culpable for more death please don't
politicize this virus it exploits the
differences you have at the national
level if you want to be exploited and if
you want to have many more body bags
then you do it if you don't want many
more body bags then you refrain from
politicizing it it's like playing with
fire so more than ever before national
unity is important if we care about our
people if we care about our citizens
please unity at national level no using
covet for political points and then
second honest solidarity at global level
and honest leadership from the US and
China we shouldn't waste time pointing
fingers you know it's very convenient
that the people responsible for this
pandemic or the ones encouraging us not
to point fingers it's very convenient
at China which caused the pandemic
entirely if China had acted just three
weeks earlier studies show 95% of the
spread would not have happened if they'd
acted even one week earlier 66% of the
spread would not have happened
China solely responsible for this they
don't want us to point fingers the World
Health Organization which is now
mouthpiece for China they don't want us
to point fingers come on we need on its
leadership from the US and China too but
really the u.s. they're being so
dishonest most important thing to
understand this statement from the World
Health Organization director is that
that Punk is a propagandist for the
Chinese Communist Party okay his name is
Ted Rose ah Dhanam Gabrus
I'm totally mispronouncing that but
whatever he's the World Health
Organization director-general China
worked tirelessly behind the scenes to
quote news reports at the time to have
that guy installed that guy worked
before he went to the w-h-o he worked in
the government of the Marxist to
Ethiopian People's Revolutionary
Democratic Front how that regime was a
notorious regime notorious for torture
oppression and stealing elections and
while this man was the Health Minister
over there he was responsible for
covering up three cholera outbreaks this
is a bad hombre he's not an honest actor
he's not acting in good faith he's a
mouthpiece for Chinese Communists you
know the line we've heard the whole time
from the left with this pandemic is if
you question them if you question the
experts if you question the politicians
you are responsible for more people
dying for their policy you know if you
have you question Donald Trump that
makes you a patriot but if you question
their guys then you are responsible for
more people dying obviously the WHI was
using the same line Chinese Communists
generally are very good at exploiting
American political divisions they've
been good at that for a long time so
President Trump now responds to the
World Health Organization because a the
prompting event for why they are even
going after the US right now is the u.s.
is threatening
to cut funding so just Donald Trump back
down I don't think so the world
organization today warned against
politicizing I agree with that and he
said that I think that that consequence
of this politicization could actually
create more body bags it's a pretty good
image and what Oh
what do you believe the concept was of
the u.s. pulling out its funding up the
W I think you said more body bags I
think we would have done and he would
have been much better serving the people
that he's supposed to serve if they gave
a correct analysis I mean everything was
I said China centric everything was
gonna be fine
no human-to-human keep the borders open
he wanted me to keep the borders open I
closed the borders despite him and that
was a hard decision to make at the time
we were all together we made a decision
against the World Health Organization so
when he says politicizing he's
politicizing that shouldn't be but look
we spend four hundred and fifty billion
dollars four hundred and fifty two
billion dollars almost five hundred
billion last year hundreds of billions
in previous years and they got to do
better than that they got to do better
when you talk about politics I can't
believe he's talking about politics when
you look at the relationship they have
to China so China spends 42 million we
spend 450 million and everything seems
to be China's way that's not right it's
not fair to us and honestly it's not
fair to the world who is politicizing
the virus it's not us okay it's the
World Health Organization primarily and
all of their lackeys and China the World
Health Organization didn't lift a finger
to stop this pandemic until February
okay we knew that this was in China now
as early as October but whu-oh didn't do
that then when the WTO David though
through the whu-oh acted do you know
what they did they finally sent a couple
experts months and months later and then
their biggest campaign was to get people
to stop calling at the Chinese
coronavirus their biggest campaign was
not a medical campaign to stop the
pandemic it was a PR campaign for China
and now w-h-o says don't politicize the
virus they're accusing Trump of filling
up body bags because he would have the
audacity to to question our vaunted
Marxist leaders at the whu-oh and in
China I don't think so okay this is the
perfect time to be criticizing the w-h-o
and it's a perfect time to defund them
as well we've got to get to Ellen
DeGeneres I know Ellen doesn't feature
into our show very much but Ellen is
getting in a lot of trouble on the left
and the right and I think we've got to
defend her we'll get to that in just a
second I will get to why the models
turned out to be so wrong and what we
can do about that first I got to thank
our friends over at Rock Auto if your
car is having trouble oh man is Rock
Auto a godsend right now very difficult
to go to brick and mortar these days
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and then someone
demanding quick answers to things like
hey is your Odyssey an L X or an e X and
then they usually just have to order the
part online anyway they probably go to
rockauto.com and then they charge you
twice as much if you have the internet
you have access to rockauto.com at your
desk and in your pocket the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate so easy to navigate that even I
can navigate it okay rockauto.com always
offers the lowest price as possible it's
not changing them all the time based on
gimmicks or you know kind of like
airlines not changing the prices all the
time why spend up to twice as much for
the same parts go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then right Knolls
Canada wles in there how did you hear
about us box and they will know that we
sent you and you will be sure to get the
best parts for your car or truck
rockauto.com all right Ellen is in
trouble
ellen is in trouble because she's
broadcasting from her home right now
just like a lot of people on TV are
they've had home studios set up and so
she's broadcasting from there but she
got in trouble because she said this
whole quarantine feels really bad it
actually feels like you're in jail being
in quarantine is that people this is
like being in jail is what it is it's
mostly because I'm
wearing the same clothes for 10 days and
everyone in here is gay the jokes that I
have I feel bad for the kids at home
all the college students all the parents
I feel bad for a lot of people but I
think that a lot of people out there
need words of encouragement and that's
what I want to do I want to spread light
where there's shade okay first of all
great joke it's a very funny joke right
because I haven't changed my clothes in
10 days and everyone in here is gay but
the point she's making is true as well
the point was a setup for a joke so she
should get leeway anyway but the point
she's making is true which is in part
why the joke is funny it feels like
we're in jail a lot of people responded
to this I said I've served time and
jails nothing like you're a
multi-million dollar house you don't
know nothing about Jail you're so out of
touch no it is like Jail okay and I
think that the critics of Ellen right
now are confused because they think that
the defining feature of jail is how nice
the beds are or you know how big the
windows are that's not the defining
feature of jail the defining feature of
jail is whether or not you're allowed to
leave okay and increasingly we are not
allowed to leave our homes in LA they've
just said if you leave your home without
a face mask on you're gonna be in
trouble with the government in Hamilton
County Ohio we talked about this one
yesterday there is a prosecutor out
there who is charging people with
felonious assault if they leave their
homes we are for all intents and
purposes in certain parts of this
country in jail right now and we might
be in jail with golden handcuffs we
might be in jail with nice you know
amenities and luxury but doesn't matter
how much luxury you've got if you're not
free to leave and so it's a very good
point made by Ellen and they're pretty
funny joke as well and you know I think
people should just lay off her I think
she's she's saying the right things when
a lot of people around here are saying
the wrong things now we've got to get
back to Joe Biden because another
television personality Whoopi Goldberg
has made a major faux pas and it just
shows you what to expect for the next
several months as we plot our way to
November the fawning the praise the
absolute ignorance is not just for
whoopee it's typical of a lot of people
on the Left Whoopi Goldberg has an idea
for the Biden administration the Biden
administration the hill pick is vice
president in his cabinet but the Surgeon
General obviously should be none other
than dr. Jill Biden the the word doctor
is right there in her name I'm hoping
dr. Jill becomes the Surgeon General Joe
Biden's wife I see that you know he
would never do it but she yes she's a
hell of a doctor she's an amazing
teacher but you know might might be good
for Betsy Gauss's post oh that's so
awkward because it's not awkward that
she got the doctor thing wrong it is
very confusing the people who are
teachers go by doctor and people who are
physicians go by doctor and it's
especially confusing because we think
that physicians are the real doctors but
the word doctor actually means teacher
comes from the Latin Doh chair a so
anyway I understand that it's
complicated with the title what gets
what be in trouble she goes oh yeah Jill
she's an amazing doctor Shaw she's an
amazing doctor of course she should be
Surgeon General then we find out Whoopi
doesn't know first of all anything about
Joe Biden's career she doesn't even know
what Joe Biden does as a career Joe
Biden has a doctorate in education she's
not a doctor of medicine she's not a PhD
in English or history she's a doctor of
Education she's a teacher of teaching
she'd be an amazing Surgeon General this
is what we're gonna hear now until
November is everything Joe Biden ever
did is wonderful everything Jill Biden
ever did is wonderful probably
everything hunter Biden ever did is
wonderful they've already gotten to that
point in the New York Times giving him
fawning profiles for his artwork well
he's refusing to pay child support on
his last most recent kid not the most
recent one but the last most recent one
that's what you can expect and we should
be able to see very clearly what's going
on with Joe Biden we should be able to
see very clearly what's going on in our
national pandemic as well and as you
know increasingly we're not allowed to
question anything that's going on well
dr. Burks gave us a little bit of truth
yesterday
during the White House press briefing on
the coronavirus because you remember we
were told two million Americans are
going to die maybe more then they
downgraded it then they downgraded it
then they downgraded it so right now dr.
Burks is essentially admitting that the
models were wrong I think all of you
many of you have done the analysis of
the same models that we utilized and if
you do the models of the models you end
up with that range at the same time we
carefully looked at Italy and Spain and
we are doing much better in many cases
than several other countries and we're
trying to understand that we believe
that our health care delivery system in
the United States is quite extraordinary
I know many of you are watching the act
now model and the ìiî hme model from and
they have consistently decreased the
number the mortality from over almost
ninety thousand eighty eight eighty six
thousand down to eighty one thousand and
now down to sixty one thousand that is
modeled on what America is doing you
know I hate to say I told you so you
know I hate to do that but I told you so
early on we heard numbers 2 million 1
million then it got revised down but
when we heard those two million numbers
I said that that was almost certainly
not true right then we heard revised
down numbers five hundred thousand four
I said at the time almost certainly not
true then we heard America is gonna be
just like Italy we're gonna be hit just
as hard we might be head harder when
that happened I said mmm that is
probably not true because Italy has the
second oldest population in the world
they greet each other by kissing and
everybody smokes and they haven't had a
functioning government since Octavia
remember I said that and people attacked
me on the left and the right people on
the right - they said oh we're gonna be
Italy in two days where it's gonna be
exactly like Italy the hospitals are
gonna be completely overrun it's gonna
be a disaster you're gonna see hundreds
of thousands if not millions of
Americans die guess what
turns out I was right and the skeptics
were right it's not just me there were
many other people who were skeptical of
these models that had
I'll shut down the entire government and
one thing that's worth pointing out here
because what you're gonna hear from now
until eternity is nobody taking any
responsibility here what you're gonna
hear is right it would have been 2
million if we hadn't social distanced oh
yeah if it would have been 2 million if
we hadn't shut down the global economy
there's no evidence of that ok perhaps
not the initial models but all the
models we've seen after that we're
taking into account the measures that
the United States was taking the social
distancing this shutdown the
hand-washing the stupid masks it was
taking into account all of that ok and
the models were still outrageously
hyperbolic somebody ought to be held
responsible for this and I don't even
mean to hold the experts responsible the
experts are just doing what experts do
which is get things wrong ok the
epidemiologists were just doing what
Emma D me ologists do which is get
things wrong epidemiology is nearly as
fake a science as climatology ok it is
an imprecise science that's based on
predicting the future with yet which
nobody can do the people we've got a
hold responsible or the politicians who
were so hyperbolic who overreacted who
left to shut everything down because now
we are hearing from the vaunted experts
themselves that the hysterical alarmists
were wrong and the skeptics were right
got so much more to get to including the
mailbag first I got to thank our friends
over at LifeLock you know there are some
people out there who seem like they're
prepared for anything right they've got
you know they've got everything prepared
I'm not one of those people ok but you
know them we all know them if you have a
cut they'll give you a band-aid if you
need a battery they will have multiple
sizes on hand triple-a double-a if
they're worried about identity theft
well they'll only monitor their credit
which just isn't enough ok branches seam
breaches rather breaches seem like
they're happening more and more these
days and with your breached information
like I don't know your name your social
security number more criminals can
commit identity theft and there a lot of
breaches going on especially around tax
time when you're sending your
information all over the place
join LifeLock today
okay no one can prevent and identify
theft no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions and
all businesses but with breaches on the
rise doesn't it make sense to be
prepared joined LifeLock you get up to
25% off your first year go to LifeLock
dot-com / Knowles Cana wles that's life
lock dot-com / Knowles - save 25% if
your daily wire subscriber go check out
the all access show it's great I did one
last night it's initially for all access
members we're doing it now for all
members because we're just quarantined
it's fun show we hang out for an hour we
do it all the time at 5:00 p.m. Pacific
8:00 p.m. Eastern if you haven't joined
go do that right now Daly wire.com /
subscribe we'll be right back with the
mailbag end with a quick clip from a
chat I had with my friend Glenn Beck
all right we've got to get to the
mailbag but first I want to play just a
short clip of an interview I had with my
friend Glenn Beck we're gonna post the
whole interview on YouTube but I wanted
to chat with him because one whenever
we're in actual catastrophes Glenn is
like the Prophet he is the voice of one
crying out in the wilderness and he's
really good on issues of monetary policy
on explaining the Federal Reserve a lot
of the issues that are going on right
now that people aren't talking about
because they're not the top line of the
pandemic so he gets into that end also
very importantly Glenn Beck has a new
book coming out arguing with socialists
this is in the vein of my favorite book
he ever wrote called arguing with idiots
which is absolutely terrific if you
haven't read it yet and arguing with
socialists is really great too so for
just a couple minutes here here is my
friend Glenn Beck
[Music]
the Fed controls that by how much they
had how much how many dollars they print
right now they are taking and stealing
your savings by inflating the dollar you
won't be able to buy as much as you
could just a few weeks ago very very
soon so it punishes people who save well
and we say by the rules we see this kind
of in numeracy you know this just
inability that keep track of numbers
playing out in some of the characters in
your book and I fear now that we're
talking about two trillion dollar
stimulus and then the feds going to
lever that up to six trillion dollars in
lending and when we're talking these
huge numbers that people are gonna lose
sight of what that means the value of a
dollar maybe you know the aoc green New
Deal is 93 trillion dollars by some
estimates over ten years but you know
that's that means it's what nine point
three trillion dollars each year we're
already talking about ten trillion
dollar proposals is there a way that we
get out of this and I know you talk
about eco socialism in the book is there
a way we get out of the corona virus and
the left says look we can raise the
money we just saw it last week why can't
we have the green New Deal yes the
reason why they're saying six trillion
dollars is remember that two trillion
that we've just passed yeah was actually
six trillion because the Federal Reserve
put in another four trillion dollars
that they don't have they just printed
the way to get out of that is to do
modern monetary theory it is why if you
read the last chapter you'll understand
it it is really why the Socialists have
come up with it and why they love it so
much because they don't need to tax
anybody they don't need to talk about
raising income tax they don't have to
worry about how we're gonna pay for it
you see the printing press over there
all we do is turn that on that's how we
pay for it that's modern monetary theory
it is so crazy because it is the
simplest idea what if you just say it's
valued at that then it's valued that
then why didn't every King and every
dictator in the history of the world
come up with that they did it doesn't
work it doesn't work and they keep
pushing it and
I mean this ties in more broadly with
the popularity of socialism because
there was this very scary study came out
about a year ago which said that over
half of young Americans now identify as
socialists and that's the bad news but
the good news is only about 32 percent
can explain what socialism is so the
popularity of socialism that is this a
matter of the idea being really new and
hot and sexy or is it just a matter of
ignorance I think there's a couple of
things one if you look at somebody your
age how old are you Michael
I am I just turned 30 I'm officially an
adult by today's standards okay all
right so you remember you were 10 and
around September 11th right yeah okay so
September 11th happened and your
memories of that is it was a shock
everybody was freaking out the stock
market collapsed and they closed it down
and maybe people lost money and they
lost their jobs then your next big
memory is 2008 where the banks went
crazy you lost a lot of money nobody had
jobs now your next one is this yeah when
nobody had jobs money was tight you
couldn't get a loan people were getting
richer because the government this is a
system that if you are 30 years old
you've never seen this system work right
huh you've never seen this system
provide any kind of stability and you're
looking at your parents and you're like
my dad just lost his job they lost
everything he was just starting to turn
it around and he lost everything this is
ridiculous I don't want this but they've
never seen they've never seen actual
socialism there's a whole chapter on
Sweden and Finland and Iceland and all
these socialist countries they are not
socialist countries yeah they are
capitalist countries more free than we
are fewer regulation on business than we
have by a great deal so they're more
free they it is easier for you to start
your own business three out of the five
have lower taxes on corporations than we
do they have a big safety net
well that's not bad that's not socialism
that's a safety net all right we'll get
to the rest of that interview over on
YouTube so you can go check that out but
Glenn always so interesting especially
on those kind of topics and the book is
arguing with socialists let's get to the
mailbag I'm gonna fly through these okay
there's gonna be a speed round from
Martin hi Michael what will the
government ask the Chinese Communist
Party in regards to a compensation
damages packages for reeved families and
the destroyed livelihoods due to its
gross negligence if negligence occurred
in corporate or the company or a company
private sector and I'm not sure what
this wording is here
wouldn't they be charged with
manslaughter very possibly they would
but International Relations is not just
the private market and we're in a very
difficult situation right now because
our largest creditor is China China has
bought up so much of our debt we've also
outsourced all of our manufacturing to
China so China in some ways has us in an
unfortunate grip the people who
suggested that we do all that told us so
there's no big deal you can outsource
all of your manufacturing you'll get
cheap consumer products it's a win-win
there's no reason ever to put any
barrier up to trade it's just a win-win
now we're seeing the national security
implications of that the the way out in
the short term is to disentangle
ourselves from China we won't be able to
talk at all about punishment or
compensation until we do that and
fortunately that's what President Trump
ran on it's what he's been starting to
do in the first term and hopefully he'll
complete in the second term from Timur
hi Michael I really enjoy watching your
show and the reasoning you give behind a
lot of issues one question I had do you
think this nasty Chinese virus
originated from eating bats or from a
Wuhan Lab from which it accidentally or
not accidentally escaped thank you very
much I think that it's very possible the
virus began in nature but I think that
there are a lot of ties linking the
virus to that laboratory in Wuhan there
are a lot of questions about how the bat
that the bats that were infected could
even have gotten to the Wuhan wet market
I suspect that the Chinese government
played a much larger role in this then
people are
from Brian hi Michael there's a huge
issue that is being raised in
evangelical circles right now that I'm
wondering if you can address it's the
idea of corporates in these days there's
a lot of talk about how on top of our
individual sins we bear a portion of the
collective or systemic sins of our
societies like the collective sin of
slavery or racism
I personally reject this notion and I
think it comes from cultural Marxism
what do you think yeah I think that's
about right you sin individually that's
how you sin you're not responsible for
somebody else's sin you sin individually
now we all bear original sin which is
what happened when our first father
Adams sinned and sin and death pervaded
the world and that is just the world in
which we live now we are tainted by that
but the sins that we commit are our own
problems
this idea of corporate sin this idea
that you know look I don't need to worry
so much about my sins but I am
responsible for my great great great
great grand daddy's friend who owned a
slave that is I think actually another
form of pride it's a way of saying I
don't need to focus on my own sins I
need to worry about somebody else's sins
a long time ago who wasn't me but I'm
such a good person that I'll bear some
responsibility for that
that's an inversion of the reality of
our relationship to sin and we should
focus on the man in the mirror from Jay
most esteemed and knowledgeable knowles
I was raised as a non-believer and
became virulent ly anti theist but
eventually listening to all of you as
well as other apologists I came to
believe I had been wrong I now consider
myself a Christian but I have not yet
chosen a church I hope to choose between
the big three catholicism protestantism
and orthodoxy what pulled you toward the
Catholic Church was it solely family
background or was there more to it for
you no it was not solely family
background I was a cradle Catholic and
then I fell away for ten years
actually when I reverted to the church I
was initially attracted by Protestants
by evangelicals and by Calvinists even
and by you know versions and
denominations of Christianity that I
don't really agree with anymore but they
helped to bring me in and then I arrived
back at the Catholic Church because I
think the historical claims of the
Catholic Church are true and I found it
to be a little strange that virtually
every Christian for all of history
believed basically the exact same thing
until about the sixteenth century and
then even around that time all the major
Protestant thinkers Martin Luther or
Zwingli Calvin Wesley these guys
believed many things that would now be
called almost exclusively Catholic for
instance in the perpetual virginity of
Mary which all of all of them believed
in Calvin said there wasn't enough
evidence on either side of the question
but they all accept it as possible if
not probable even back then and then
this has branched out so for the big
three you're gonna face another big
problem which is that the big three are
actually two and then like thirty
thousand because obviously Protestantism
is not one unified Church but it's I
think it's about thirty thousand
denominations so I guess thirty thousand
and two are your choices but I think
that the historical claims of the church
are true the Catholic Church I think
that you know Christ built his church
upon that rock of Peter and I think that
he gave Peter the keys to the kingdom of
heaven and whatever he binds on earth
will be bound in heaven whatever he
loses on earth will be loosed in heaven
he breathed on the Apostles gave them
the Holy Spirit and the power to forgive
sins and whose sins they forgive are
forgiven and whose sins they retain are
retained and on a broader level I think
that that sacrament the sacramental
nature of the church is very important
that church is incarnation 'el it's not
just in our minds we can't just live
stream the church forever we have to
engage in the sacraments really and the
the clearest form of that is the Blessed
Sacrament which is the unity of heaven
and earth the unity of the physical and
the metaphysical it's it is a host that
becomes literally the body and blood of
Christ from Reve greetings to the least
execrable Michael Knowles I know I'm 16
and currently attending college I'm a
very motivated person usually but lately
my motivation has been in rapid decline
especially during school as someone who
has done a lot of work in life can you
give any insight in how to rekindle
motivation yes I can do that this
happens to everybody doesn't matter how
motivated you are when you get off your
rhythm you can get depressed you can get
sluggish you stop doing things you have
to recognize that there is a purpose
okay a purpose to your life a purpose to
this week a purpose to this day a
purpose to the
that you're working on you only have so
many minutes you are going to die
someday and you were going to be held
accountable for what you did with the
time that you have if that's not a
motivating factor I don't know what
could be before we go I want to get down
to a question that someone emailed in
this is from Maddie and it's an
important question because I've heard
this crop up a few times
Maddie asks Michael there is one
pro-choice argument that I've had
trouble articulating response to Bill
Nye says Bill Nye you know that
brilliant theologian not only not a
theologian also not a scientist but Bill
Nye says a lot of men of European
descent are passing reproductive laws
based on ignorance many many more eggs
are fertilised than become humans eggs
get or get fertilized sperm get accepted
by OVA a lot but that's not all you need
how does an M the early embryo mortality
and the fact that the design of our
bodies seems to not value a fertilized
egg fit in with what I believe which is
that life begins at conception when a
unique set of DNA is formed Thanks
there's a difference between natural
death and murder is the answer that's
how everybody dies eventually that
doesn't mean it's okay to murder people
because you could just reframe the
question and say you know I was looking
around and I found out that everybody
dies so how do i reconcile my belief
that it's bad to murder people with the
obvious point that nature doesn't care
about that because everybody dies right
because there's a difference between the
things that happen in nature and the
moral order right so there's a
difference between the natural fact of
our death and decay and the moral
question of whether I will hasten that
decay and I will attack somebody else I
also love that Bill Nye says he singles
out white men for some reason he says a
lot of European men of European descent
are passing these laws
first of all 50% of pro-life people are
women but Bill Nye is a man of European
descent and he's passing he's saying a
lot of things that are coming from
ignorance as well so I would just point
out that the facts of the natural world
are are not prescriptive necessarily
in the moral order we see plenty of
things rape rape and killing and
pillaging and burning happens in the
natural world all the time doesn't make
it a good thing all right that's our
show
how's that for an uncontroversial
statement to end on it's bad to murder
oK we've got so much more to do but
we'll just have to see you on Monday
unless you listen to the Ben Shapiro
show today on radio I'm gonna be filling
in for that maybe we'll have some
verdict with Ted Cruz come out this
weekend look we got a lot of stuff on
the horizon in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director havel
Winooski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen